der marti fischer der ist ein so netter
kerl da ist es echt schwierig sich die
gemeinen fragen fürs fragen lotto
einfallen zu lassen aber er hat dann
doch wenn man ein bisschen nachdenkt ein
paar schwachpunkte und da legen wir mit
unseren gemein fragen den gesalzenen
finger in die wunde
nicht das kann unglaublich daß mein
talent dieses jahr das kannten das was
gelernt das klappe schlagen ja aber das
war ein das war eines der seminare was
du extra belegt und wurde viele tausend
euro bezahlt genau aber jetzt ganz das
sensationell aber jetzt wird viel
schwieriger das hast du nicht trainiert
das ist das fragen lauter du weißt
nichts zu sagen hat rein gezielt gezielt
rote frage rot und ritsch ratsch fast
noch schöner handarbeit jeder alles
selber getackert und geknipst und
geschnitten oder so ähnlich
so nah kommt steht nicht so an
bist du dem harten mediengeschäft
überhaupt gewachsen ich behaupte mal
vielleicht ein wenig aber ich muss noch
viel lernen
ja also ich sag mal wo sind da die wo du
denken oh das wird mir jetzt sagen
strengt
vielleicht so das durchhaltevermögen ja
auch
und trotzdem weiterzumachen auch wenn es
scheiße läuft
also sagen bei zu bleiben aber ich denke
mal mit dem nötigen also dahingehend
habe ich schon den entsprechenden
ehrgeiz ich würde das auch
da kenne ich keine gnade das ist gut
ich habe wirklich das durchhaltevermögen
ist das entscheidende dass ihr
entscheiden absolut entscheidend auch
wenn es wenn einen keiner interessiert
oder so
carlo grünn
immer abwechselnd würde ich mal aus
kanada
woher hast du deine sympathische
ausstrahlung
von mir keine ahnung also du hättest ja
ich habe
als er die langen haare hatte und zwar
ist lederklamotten und sonst was noch in
den läden lena haben aber schwarz ja
schon da hat es ja wahrscheinlich nicht
so eine sympathische ausstrahlung jetzt
doch auch ich hab ich habe irgendwie
immer geschäftig weiß nicht ich glaube
ich
dass das kam so der also meint meinen
schalen mit schirm charme und melone
also also vielleicht auch mein ganz
gesunden humor
und dass ich immer so bemüht bin
freundlich zu sein und höflich
ohne grund würde ich keine so einfach
auf die fresse hauen sagen wir so aber
ist das nicht gerade in der branche
schwierig ist das nicht leicht fehler
immer freundlich zu sein
ja das kann sein aber
aber man kann es ja lernen auch
irgendwie mit mit also nicht immer ja zu
sagen sie doch ist dieses schöne
fernsehwerbung wo dann wurde gesagt und
wieso wir sind alle ja sager blabla ja
ja so ein testbild farbbalken mit diesen
diesen ton und dann so kannst du auch
mal nein sagen die finde ich klasse sind
ich arbeite daran nein zu sagen auch mal
oder oder mal nicht ganz immer so
rasch zu kriegen so zu sagen was ich
sowieso nicht machen irgendwann diese
krise oder sehen sie wollen nicht ein
arzt wird er wie ein messias schleimen
ja kleiner also schlicht tue ich
eigentlich ich hoffe dass ich es nicht
bewusst machen
oder nicht unter wasser überhaupt
energie einfach nicht
warum bist du nicht total abgegrast
promis ja
schon muss ich ja wenn marcel ist ja
reich ranickis öfteren des öfteren jahr
gut stefan raab hat ja ich glaube vor
max giermann auch nie wirklich jemand
versucht ja ich
probiere mich ja auch teilweise an
andere sachen wo vorher keiner so
recht spongebob kenne ich jetzt nicht so
viele die den machen hennes bender macht
den ja ja ok in seinen shows auch
manchmal aber aber im prinzip also hast
du manchmal abgegrast und manchmal hab
ich abgebrochen machst du so gerhard
schröder zum beispiel ist auch einer von
der kategorie ja weil
keine ahnung weil sie einfach
dazugehören glauben okay ich glaube ihm
paroli geschäft oder oder halt in der in
der sparte parodie
imitationen kommt man gar nicht drum rum
was ist eine paraderolle paraderolle
beim liebling zum beispiel eigentlich
nur ein bischen helge schneider ja ich
mag den total gerne nicht nur weil er
weil er sonst total tollen humor hat
sondern war auch so unglaublich begabt
jazzmusiker ist und weil er den weil er
den applaus nicht sucht wie andere zb
sondern sondern er nimmt ihnen somit
wenn wer ihn bekommt sein das macht ihn
auch so sympathisch
helge schneider ist bei mir ganz oben
dabei
so
möchte der geht nicht an dem worüber
mehr
so
woher hast du dein
ausnahmetalent ich weiß es nicht
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen auch von
meinem opa ich glaube das kann es sein
weil ja du bist du ganz mich ankommen
weil der mit mir wie früher ständig in
irgendwelchen akzenten dialekten
sonstwie geredet hat auch heute noch und
ich glaube also keine ahnung habe ich
daran irgendwelche szenen würde dann so
so im keller weil er kommt eine eine
eine elektronische dartscheibe kann denn
im keller hängen und wir können dann
irgendwie so gesprochen ganz einfach
irgendwie nicht weil sie das das hat
mich auch total geprägt
sobald der ausweise schuld da er danke
oper das sams europa heißt jörg
janke opa york
der wird sich freuen wenn er das sieht
ja
das ist auch gut so also er ist sowieso
schon im internet ich habe mit computern
mit alex habe ich ja in den partnerkanal
ist er musste ich musste er neulich auch
vor die kamera tritt also ist hier
verlinkt
ich habe einen partner hat könnt ihr
übrigens auch mal abonnieren weil das
ist ein sehr interessantes projekt das
wir da haben
partners partner also ja okay wir sind
mittlerweile auch partner mit dem kanal
und jasons partner ja genau jetzt hat
der dass der name nicht mehr diesen
unangenehmen beigeschmack
okay wir warten jetzt nicht wie bleibt
so locker keine ahnung ich habe
irgendwann gelernt dass das irgendwie so
das ist
dass ich das doch irgendwie überspielen
kann so meine aufgeregtheit wenn ich zum
beispiel dann
irgendwelche sprüche machen oder
in solchen momenten fange ich auch an
sowie sind helge schneider zu machen
und dass das finden die leute
lustig und ich freue mich einfach dann
ich bemühe mich dann einmal durchzuatmen
dann geht's
das ist einfach so tief durchatmen
das ist vielleicht auch das er
eigentlich geheim sind jetzt in diesem
video versteckt wenn man nervös ist tief
durchatmen und dann geht alles viel
langsamer
wieder rot wir sind ja alle ausgiebig
und erschöpfen waren wurde ja
baba ist das kalt gewonnen wächst die
ihr der erfolg nicht über den kopf
ich bemühe mich am boden zu bleiben
weil das ist jetzt auch nichts
weltbewegendes wenn man jetzt zum
beispiel
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das gestern
erzählt habe
wenn man hier jemand fragen würde kennen
sie mich
woher auch wenn man jetzt fragen würde
kennen sie den beat boxer alberto dann
würden auch vielleicht einige sagen nein
wer ist das ne die sich auf youtube
rumtreiben die kennen uns ja würde mal
behaupten
und deswegen wächst mit der erfolg auch
nicht über den kopf auch nicht so durch
die durch die fernsehauftritte oder so
es ist natürlich cool was da passiert
und es fängt an zu nieseln ich habe hier
noch kurz vor der letzten fragen aber es
ist kein grund durchzudrehen
ritsch
ratsch letzte frage gott sei dank waren
wir positiv auf und warum ist denn jetzt
regenwolke pinkelt auf kopf meine freese
wie konntest du die die den
boom die ohnehin nicht nicht da ist ein
artikel zu viel richtig willkommen
zurück die den secret talents award so
locker erinnert ich weiß es nicht so
dass die leute einfach gut ich hab ja
teilgenommen und gedacht ich bin sowieso
nicht das ist übrigens ein
erfolgsgeheimnis glaube ich in teilen ja
glaube ich auch also ich hab ich habe
überhaupt nicht damit gerechnet das war
so als ich bin aus allen wolken gefallen
als dann die e mail ist und den top 25
ich weiß nicht so locker habe ich denn
noch gar nicht gewonnen es war ja nach
harter konkurrenz nur die handys der
west kanada der mit seinen gitarren
künsten das ist auch unglaublich hat ist
ja vorher gedacht das gibts gar nicht
also dass wir sehen dann hat er mir
etwas vorgespielt dass wir dann da in
berlin gestanden haben für vor der show
sind und diese die drei fußball
freestyler ist auch der wahnsinn
also so locker war das gar nicht das war
wirklich
harte konkurrenz ja aber du hast es
geschafft aber ich hab's geschafft das
ist mir bis jetzt unbegreiflich wieder
super wir können das jetzt noch so lange
ziehen bisher noch nicht klatschnass
sind ja ich glaube das war wir können
aber auch sagen hey super vielen dank
danke für die einladung ich danke dass
du gekommen ist gerne wir sind mal
gespannt was auch nicht anders es ist
aber sehr oft ist man natürlich das
finde ich wirklich
höchst interessant wie eben auch so
jemand der nicht in dem casting war wo
du bist natürlich danke kassen aber
letztlich der oderstraße nach oben
gekommen ist was daraus wird das ist
schon mega interessant und man kann es
ja immer auf youtube verfolgen das ist
ja auch
da guck mal ich würde clavinova und ich
bemühe mich auch übrigens falls sie doch
irgendwie so mega tief in die
fernsehwelt eintauchen sollte also ich
also youtube dass ich immer auf youtube
irgendwie so bleiben das ist ja quasi so
die wurzeln da haben sich ja wie sollte
man nicht hat sollte